[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález por donde
comenzar para analizar la situación en
afganistán son múltiples las aristas el
gran punto de quiebre fue la retirada de
las tropas de eeuu y sus aliados
internacionales
inmediatamente el talibán recuperó
terreno hasta llegar a kabul la capital
afgana tan rápido que la comunidad
internacional apenas podía creer que 20
años de presencia militar extranjera se
desvanecieran en cuestión de horas y
minutos y días quedan muchas dudas sobre
la mesa que falló por parte de la
estrategia de eeuu y sus aliados 20 años
después como se ve este renovado talibán
que ahora da entrevistas dice que
respetará los derechos humanos y que
quiere instaurar un emirato este
resurgimiento del talibán entonces
también que le dice a otros grupos
rebeldes como al shabab a hamás la yihad
islámica al qaeda incluso al diezmado
estado islámico que papel va a jugar
china qué papel va a jugar rusia qué
papel juegan los vecinos pakistán e irán
un poco más lejos qué papel va a tener
turquía qatar arabia saudita y el peso
que representa toda esta situación para
la política exterior de eeuu qué va a
pasar con las mujeres qué futuro es el
que la espera a afganistán ese es el
tema de debate hoy aquí en france 24
pero antes comienzo poniéndolos en
contexto veamos quién es el talibán
los insurgentes talibanes logran auparse
en el poder por primera vez en 1996 en
1998 ya controlaban el 90% del
territorio su nombre proviene de la
palabra thalif estudiante el grupo ha
trabajo originalmente a radicalizados
muyaidines o combatientes por la yihad
afganos y extranjeros que con
financiación estadounidense lucharon
contra las tropas soviéticas hasta su
retirada en 1989 los fundamentalistas
liderados entonces por el mulá mohammad
omar basaron su agenda en la
interpretación rigorista de la ley
sharía introduciendo castigos físicos la
pena capital- erradicando cualquier
expresión cultural y despojando las
mujeres de todos sus derechos pero
también se nutrieron de la influencia
tribal pastún desde la frontera
afgano-paquistaní donde comienzan a
agruparse en 1994 su poder no se
entiende sin el apoyo de pakistán desde
su nacimiento el talibán se alimentó de
la ideología suní de pakistán y es en el
vecino país donde se refugiaron sus
líderes tras su caída en 2001 con la
invasión de eeuu como respuesta a los
atentados del 11-s puesto que el grupo
protegió osama bin laden jefe de al
qaeda mientras planeaba los ataques
terroristas durante 20 años de invasión
el talibán permaneció a la sombra en
territorio vecino planeando la campaña
insurgente para recuperar el poder en
afganistán en febrero de 2020 eeuu y los
islamistas firmaron un histórico acuerdo
que establecía el calendario para la
retirada de las tropas extranjeras del
territorio mientras impulsaba un diálogo
con el gobierno afgano para poner fin a
la guerra civil sin embargo después de
años de un conflicto desgastado y sin
atención mediática el fin de las
operaciones internacionales en 2014 el
grupo talibán reafirmó su célebre frase
vosotros tenéis los relojes nosotros
tenemos el tiempo veinte años más tarde
la bandera blanca del autodenominado
emirato ondea en el palacio presidencial
de kabul
afganistán es un país con una historia
de guerras de disputas un cruce de
caminos entre asia central e india- y
también entre oriente y occidente en
cierta manera un país de tribus de
señores de guerra un país netamente
rural pobre conocido por los analistas
internacionales por ser el lugar en
donde han caído o han perdido allí
varios imperios ni los mismos afganos
han podido estabilizar el país a lo
largo de su historia tampoco lograron
por supuesto ni el imperio británico ni
los soviéticos y pues ahora eeuu tampoco
está su historia
la guerra en afganistán comenzó a la
sombra de los ataques del 11 de
septiembre cuando el jefe de al qaeda
osama bin laden fue protegido por el
talibán en afganistán
un mes después eeuu decidió invadir el
país el 7 de octubre 2001
estas acciones cuidadosamente planeadas
están diseñadas para interrumpir el uso
de afganistán con una base de
operaciones terroristas y para atacar la
capacidad militar del régimen talibán
los talibanes que profesan una línea
dura del fundamentalismo islámico habían
llegado al poder cinco años antes con el
apoyo del gobierno paquistaní en su
mandato los talibanes prohibieron la
música el arte y la educación a las
mujeres pronto las fuerzas
estadounidenses vencieron al grupo
insurgente retirándose a pakistán y a
otros países en 2004 a raíz de las
primeras elecciones democráticas del
país hamid karzai enemigo de los
talibanes llegó al poder el grupo
insurgente lejos de desaparecer se
enfrentó a las fuerzas afganas y formó
una resistencia financiada en parte por
el tráfico de drogas
paralelamente cuando barack obama
sucedió a george w.bush como presidente
del país prometió retirar las tropas
pero una escalada de violencia lo llevó
a mandar más soldados en 2010 100 mil
tropas estadounidenses estaban
territorio además de 50.000 tropas de la
otan el mundo no puede permitirse el
precio que deberá pagar si afganistán
vuelve a caer en el caos o si al qaeda
opera sin controlar después del
asesinato de blindada en el 2011 una
parte de las tropas se retiró sin
embargo otra se quedó apoyando el
entrenamiento de las fuerzas del
gobierno los talibanes continuaron sus
ataques
primero las tropas extranjeras deben
irse solo después la paz será posible en
el fondo la toma de kabul le da un giro
20 años de guerra en la que 3.500
soldados extranjeros cerca de 51 mil
civiles y 69 mil militares afganos
murieron en los enfrentamientos
para analizar este tema o intentar
analizar este tema hemos invitado a
maría teresa aya ella es analista
internacional y coordinadora de la
maestría de asuntos internacionales de
la universidad externado en bogotá en
colombia también está con nosotros
caillet mccarry él es ex diplomático
estadounidense fue responsable de la
política del hemisferio occidental
europa y de los derechos humanos y
también está con nosotros manuel raydán
analista internacional docente también
de la universidad externado de colombia
en la ciudad de bogotá ustedes también
hacen parte de esta conversación y
pueden dejar todos sus comentarios a
través de las redes sociales no se
encuentran como france24
arroba sant y luego que es mi cuenta
personal tanto en facebook como en
instagram pueden encontrar una encuesta
en línea también está en twitter esta
misma encuesta para que ustedes opinen
sobre este tema pues ya tenemos el
contexto vamos a comenzar entonces con
el análisis comienzo aquí en el estudio
con maría tereza que estaba
acompañándonos acá en el estudio
france24 maría tereza hubo un fallo de
cálculo un fallo en el análisis estas
son las palabras que cito de la
canciller alemana angela merkel en
cuanto a la situación en afganistán y
por eso el caos que se está viviendo
ahora que bien si no hubo un fallo
podemos decir que no se esperaba que
fuera tan rápido que los talibanes se
tomaran el poder pero si se sabía que
tarde que temprano iban a llegar al
poder la inteligencia se divide en 24
meses señor presidente no se preocupe
usted sabe que en 24 meses
puede jugar esos 24 meses a darle más
ayuda a unos que a otros no tal vez son
18 hillary clinton en mayo dijo tenemos
que estar preparados cuando nos
retiremos acá vamos a tener dos grandes
problemas la retoma del cuerpo los
talibanes y el tema de los refugiados
afganos que no van a saber a dónde ir lo
dijo en mayo han pasado tres meses que
pasó porque el gobierno americano no
estaba preparado cómo es posible que
hillary que ya no está en el gobierno
tuviera esta información hoy en día los
inteligencia se echan la culpa unos a
otros pero el caso es que se sabía que
iba a llegar los talibanes tal vez no
tan rápido y rayaron los cálculos de la
inteligencia y yo estaría mirando
fuertemente al por qué falló la
inteligencia americana en este momento
de trasladar esa pregunta a caleb
mccarry para que nos responda le falló
el cálculo a eeuu falló la inteligencia
de eeuu y simplemente la situación se
salió de control no estimaban que la
crisis fuera a ser tal
es posible pero yo creo que eso ya
estaba marcado desde la distracción no
entró en conversaciones separadas sobre
cómo
los talibanes
era una era una pero era una
conversación sin la presencia del
gobierno de afganistán lo cual
a mí me llamó mucho la atención entonces
creo que puede ser más había sido más
precipitado la precipitada la carica y
la del gobierno es el presente gran y
pero no creo que esté bien debió haber
sido gran sorpresa
y manuel reirán también en la ciudad de
bogotá le hago la misma pregunta un
fallo de cálculo que le falló a eeuu en
su estrategia para desatar esta crisis
política en afganistán
muy buenos días para todos yo creo que
en efecto fueron un sinfín de problemas
de errores el primero que dio fue que
los neoconservadores asesores de
presidente bush se consideraron al qaeda
como un enemigo que podía desafiar el
poderío de eeuu en ese año el segundo es
que hubo una información que al parecer
no era
materializado en los hechos reales sobre
esa estabilización que realmente tenían
allí lo tercero es también que los
países eeuu y la otan no lograban tener
o cubrir todo el territorio afgano y por
esto digamos que zonas y proyectamos las
providencias o las partes lejanas de
kabul estuvieron más que todo en control
por parte de los talibán el que lo
continuaron haciendo entonces yo creo
que hubo diferentes errores que se
vieron evidenciados allí desde la misma
estrategia por ejemplo que eeuu también
establecieron una estrategia de una
guerra asimétrica cuando era una guerra
asimétrica es decir que accedí los
componentes ideológicos
identitarios y culturales jugaron un
papel protagónico y por eso vimos un eje
ganó poderosamente armado pero altamente
dependiente de la otan más dirigido con
altos grados de corrupción y por el otro
lado vimos a un ejército talibán de aves
militarmente pero fuerte ideológicamente
entonces creo que hubo una seguidilla de
errores de interpretación directamente
comunicación y análisis dentro del
escenario político y militar en
afganistán por parte de estados unidos
manuel sigo con usted hago la ronda a la
inversa y le pregunto por el talibán o
usted dice que militarmente tal vez no
estaban tan fortalecidos como uno
pensaría pero sin duda alguna vemos a un
tal evans completamente renovado un
grupo insurgente que no parece este
grupo de hombres de campo de las
provincias de afganistán se ven unas
personas mucho más preparadas dando
entrevistas dando conferencias de prensa
hablando con medios internacionales y
parece que con una estrategia muy bien
organizada de lo que quieren hacer allí
en ese país independiente que le gusten
a occidente pero claramente estamos ante
un talibán completamente diferente al
del 2001
si ya te hago yo le agregaría un
elemento importante y es que estamos
ante un talibán distinto pero también en
unas condiciones materiales políticas y
económicas a nivel internacional también
distintas en 2001 es decir hoy eeuu no
goza de esta supremacía militar y
política a nivel mundial pues militar de
alessi pero política no ni económica y
que claramente eso también genera y
tiene unos impactos dentro de la
ordenanza internacional y mundial y
regional ahora vemos un hostal yo en
muchos más organizados claramente han
tenido reuniones con alto nivel a nivel
diplomático con países como rusia que
desde el inicio pero que desde 2019 y
2020 han estado en constantes reuniones
al igual que lo hemos visto con el
presidente de turquía y entre sí
podríamos a los funcionarios también
desde moscú entonces claramente vemos un
talibán que tiene otra visión también
distinta de crear un estado propio con
sus propias reglas
mccartney le pregunto cómo ve usted a
este talibán del 2021 que ya lo decíamos
tener unas características diferentes
pero tal vez siento un poco de poder por
haber en cierta forma humillado un poco
a eeuu a nivel internacional con esta
retirada
mire no creo que haya vida
ellas aparecen
no podríamos estar ahí por siempre
apoyar
siquiera el culo desesperación
y por otro lado con los talibanes con el
talibán hay que ustedes en
ejecución al principio es lo que
señalaron pues que esto ha sido una
relación de 40 años 80 nosotros éramos
los aliados de los que serían los
califas
supone que vivimos
armas para
a hacer la guerra
a la unión soviética
después de 2001 entramos porque había un
reclamo por una respuesta a los ataques
suicidas y para mí en la sorpresa era
que cayera tan fácilmente el régimen del
o el de los talibanes en ese momento ya
tienen ellos estos 20 años
enfrentados con nosotros y nosotros
no practicamos la guerra total lo que
practicamos era ver si podemos ayudar a
afganistán progresar y abrir un espacio
entonces yo creo que los talibanes ahora
van a intentar una situación diferente
en el sentido de que la verdad es que si
se ha abierto espacios en afganistán
para las mujeres
ha habido mucha inversión estados miles
de millones de dólares si entonces yo
creo que ellos tendrán que no sólo
enfrentar una situación a nivel
diplomática internacional sino una
situación diferente dentro del país y
agregó un punto final que lo siguiente
que es esas fuerzas que no son únicas
pero por lo menos saben una cosa
conocen el poderío militar de los eeuu y
si se atreven a atacar a los intereses a
eeuu
ellos saben cuál va a ser la respuesta
claro y eso ha sido claro maría tereza
el mensaje del presidente joe biden que
si el talibán
ataca alguno de los intereses se les van
a responder militarmente pero como queda
la imagen de eeuu la política exterior
de eeuu en este momento con esta
coyuntura eso fue parte de los acuerdos
de doha que se retiraba y eeuu pero que
los talibanes se comprometían a no usar
su territorio para albergar terroristas
o preparar ataques contra eeuu para
muchos este acuerdo no fuesen una simple
cortina de humo tanto para estados
unidos como para los talibanes eeuu
tiene un acuerdo entonces dice me retiro
y no perdí la guerra y los talibanes
dicen acá un acuerdo acá además me
liberaron unos prisioneros importantes
que yo necesitaba 5.000 presos
palestinos por mil entonces ya gane
entonces fue una cortina de humo
realmente nos acuerdo mucho y ambos
salieron ganando lo que querían ganar o
por lo menos salvando un poco de su
prestigio en ese sentido el gobierno de
bailén yo creo que pierde algo pero el
momento de perder es no es un mal
momento para perder estamos todavía un
año de las próximas elecciones y la
gente se le olvida rápidamente esto es
decir pierde pero capaz que no le cueste
tanto en un futuro cercano y en cuanto a
los talibanes del ejército yo si
quisiera decir eeuu invirtió más de 2
trillones de dólares en afganistán
a contratistas que de alguna manera
devolvían la plata eeuu es decir la
gente sigue en pobreza y es los
talibanes lo aprovecharon pagándole al
ejército para que se les uniera en este
momento hay que decir que si bien el
presidente yo bailé en ese que le toca
este momento final de la retirada estas
son 20 años son cuatro gobiernos
diferentes tanto demócratas como
republicanos hay en eeuu que hicieron
frente a la situación se puede decir que
es un efecto bola de nieve de una
sucesión de errores hasta llegar a lo
que tenemos hoy diría que sí y que no
porque bardem ha sido consistente cuando
en el 2009 el presidente obama dice yo
voy a aumentar el número de tropas en
afganistán no habían encontrado todavía
bin laden bailén se opone entonces de
alguna manera él ha tenido una visión de
afganistán en la que el número de tropas
y la intervención de eeuu no era grande
para él pero por otro lado si ha sido
una bola de nieve empezó con todo el
apoyo del mundo entero detrás después de
los ataques a las torres gemelas y esto
fue disminuyendo con el paso del tiempo
el apoyo fue disminuyendo
de alguna manera ha ido entre aumentando
y disminuyendo y sin saber bien qué
hacer en afganistán y países como
decíamos al principio rusia china india
es supremamente importante porque está
en un cerco de países con los que no se
entiende muy bien hay cerca
están mirando el tema y han cambiado en
20 años pero los cuatro presidentes han
tenido el bus la política de la guerra
obama dentro de todo su premio nobel de
la paz él creía en la guerra él decía si
me toca hacer la guerra para salvar a
los americanos eso es más importante que
el nobel después trump quiso negociar y
hay que reconocerle que él fue el
primero en hablar de retiro de tropas y
vice de nerea esto pero en el fondo de
algo con lo que él estaba de acuerdo y
simplemente le está para cumplirlo soy
como yo digo veremos en el año medio en
las elecciones cuánto le cuesta y es un
efecto de bola de nieve que genera mucha
incertidumbre para teresa a nivel
internacional y le hago esta pregunta a
manuel porque hay temor que esto
le dé un poco de fuerza o haga sentir a
otros grupos rebeldes que tienen cierto
poder o que pueden estar amparados
después de lo que ha sucedido en
afganistán cuál es el mensaje entonces
que el talibán le manda con estas
acciones de los últimos días a otros
grupos como hamas al shabab el mismo
estado islámico que si bien no no no
tiene ningún tipo de relación con con el
talibán no se llevan digámoslo así pero
tienen un punto en común que es al qaeda
cuál es el mensaje para estos grupos
pueden sentir que de pronto tienen
fuerza
bueno yo no creo que exista una relación
tan directa porque también dentro de
estos conflictos en afganistán en las
respuestas en irak siria tendríamos que
esto en estos países existen unas
condiciones y unas dinámicas propias
políticas y religiosas que en muchas
ocasiones y un claro algo que comprueba
eso es que hoy ni siquiera los talibán
en afganistán tienen el completo control
de hecho a 150 kilómetros hoy en kabul
pues en el valle de pasividad se están
reuniendo los señores de la guerra
porque le quieren hacer resistencia a
los talibanes es decir que eso tampoco
es que sea un mensaje que sea una
relación causal directa para que todos
se armen ahora claramente yo creo que
más que es darle un mensaje a las otras
organizaciones que están en armas yo
también creo que es el mensaje que le
envía a los talibanes del mundo sobre
eeuu yo creo que también el retiro eeuu
de afganistán es una muestra de que eeuu
debe recobrar sus puertas para hacerle
frente a chila por las nuevas
situaciones económicas y políticas con
este país yo creo que aquí pues el
mensaje digamos con corre con lo que
dice la profesora
es que claramente no estarían los que
mandaron que una imagen de que aquí si
ganó la guerra fue lópez no está igual
si un pueblo que además histórica como
las teóricamente como santiago nos decía
pues siempre estaba en guerra y en su
mayoría de las ha ganado entonces yo
creo que más que enviarle eso digamos
que los talibán también buscan es
reconstruir su país como tal ellos no
quieren hacer la guerra santa como el
pronto lo podemos ver con la al qaeda
entonces yo creo que y digamos que cada
país tiene cada organización política y
cada vez cada nación o cada pueblo tiene
sus propias contradicciones y no creo
que eso sea tan fácil de materializar lo
de que otras organizaciones quieran
llegar al puerto como lo digo en
afganistán los talibán todavía no tienen
el control efectivo ni político ni
militar y eso también va a ser un tema
complejo para ellos que les quiero que
analicemos un poco el vecindario en el
que se encuentra afganistán es una
posición estratégica ya lo explicábamos
un puente entre dos regiones distintas
un territorio que siempre ha sido
disputado
cómo entender entonces la posición allí
de pakistán india que maría tereza lo
mencionaba como un actor importante y
también de irán que está en el otro lado
en el extremo del noroccidente de
afganistán
yo escucho mire
hay varias cosas en pakistán ellos han
mantenido desde a veces su servicio y
experiencia en vínculos con los
talibanes
desde siempre entonces y eso trae su
propio interés
entonces para ellos es algo difícil
porque también tienen territorio que
donde hay una población que espera no es
de la misma etnia que lo sacan ispansi
si tienen y tienen ahí mucho vínculo
también entonces ellos verán cómo
manejan esa situación para ellos si es
existe el riesgo de que los radicales
dentro de pakistán pueden radicalizarse
massa
en secuencia
china
crítica a estados unidos pero no va a
ser mayor los países que sí me parece
que están preocupados son los países de
asia central
vecinos y sobre todo los petistas porque
para ello se un picados en que en
afganistán les afecta ahí y ellos hasta
que han querido ver cómo colaborar con
las que vistan y pakistán
entonces yo creo que si
las repercusiones no se saben todavía y
para los
que ya entran
en el control del palacio bueno eso es
punto en el que
tienen que gobernar
y llevar el mando del país maría tereza
dos países importantes que entran en
este rompecabezas rusia que fue un país
que en cierta forma ha visto con buenos
ojos que el talibán haya recobrado el
poder el embajador ruso en kabul dijo
que le parecía que la ciudad estaba en
mejores manos ahora que hasta hace unos
días incluso rusia no ha enviado aviones
militares para sacar de allí a los
ciudadanos rusos y china también empezó
ya a hacer acercamientos diplomáticos
rusia está fascinado con afganistán
desde hace más de 200 años siempre trató
de tener un pie puesto en kabul cuando
era rusia cuando era unión soviética
ahora rusia otra vez vive fascinado con
afganistán es un vecino importante y
realmente está muy contento de que eeuu
haya salido detrás de esta cortina de
humo que llamo yo el acuerdo ellos
pretenden colaborar con los talibanes
más vale malo conocido que bueno por
conocer para ellos y realmente no
estaban de acuerdo con ninguno de los
mandatarios que había puesto o entrenado
eeuu entonces están contentos con el
tema y viendo a ver qué pueden hacer en
esa frontera y en los temas comunes de
seguridad que tienen en la zona
precisamente de los stands y de gràcia y
de asia central para china es paso
obligado de muchas de sus rutas con esta
nueva ruta de la seda que están
desarrollando en afganistán hay
minerales raros que no se han podido
explotar hasta el momento y eso a china
le llama bastante la atención para ellos
si bien no hablaban en el comercio no
importa qué color sea el gato lo
importante es que cace ratones pues acá
tenemos un gato de un color raro nuevo
pero si me funciona me permite trabajar
pues yo respeto su soberanía internet no
tengo ningún problema y que ya sabemos
cómo funciona la diplomacia china a
cambio de infraestructuras a cambio de
mejorar muchas condiciones en términos
de la infraestructura pero sin preguntar
por derechos humanos sin preguntar por
difícil sobre problemas de legarnos de
afganistán a mí me interesa que me dejen
trabajar y llegar a ciertos acuerdos acá
explotar también algunas algunos
recursos como usted le explica maría
tereza manuel le pregunto a usted
entonces por los otros vecinos de la
zona que tal vez no están tan cerca de
afganistán pero que tienen los ojos
puestos allí y hablo de qatar que fue la
sede de estos diálogos turquía que ya
empezó incluso a levantar un muro
fronterizo en la frontera que tiene con
irán para evitar la llegada de los
afganos a su territorio y otro jugador
importante aquí arabia saudita
bueno es bastante interesante santiago
ninguna pregunta porque además hemos
visto como inclusive países que entre
ellos tienen rivalidades están
terminando de reconocer a los talibán
como un nuevo gobierno legítimo no
entonces claramente turquía cada uno de
estos actores no hay que olvidar que
durante los últimos años desde la guerra
de siria o la mal llamada primavera
árabe ha habido una competencia por las
potencias regionales para saber quién va
a poder dominar esa zona y aquí hemos
visto por ejemplo el presidente drogan
de turquía jugando un papel muy
protagónico no solamente en la guerra de
libia también lo podemos ver en la libia
y claramente va a querer jugar un papel
protagónico en el escenario de
afganistán y es que claramente a quien
les importa mente en un escenario de
estabilidad política también por unos
elementos ustedes den unos recursos
económicos no es decir aquí la salida de
eeuu juega un papel importante porque le
va a dar más el juego a otras potencias
regionales y claramente aquí como
siempre hemos sabido existe una
competencia también entre los entre los
iraníes y los saudíes de quién va a
saber quién va a ser el líder de la
región entonces claramente vamos a ver
una competencia entre estas entre estas
potencias y que claramente los talibanes
van a buscar también este pragmatismo y
también yo le agregaría un elemento
adicionales frente a china y es que a
los chiles también les interesa tener un
control no solamente los temas
económicos sino también tener una
estabilidad digamos de seguridad en la
zona por los seguros no esta población
que se encuentra ubicado en la zona más
alejada de china que en la región sitian
y que claramente al final inter sectores
aquí vamos a ver un juego bien
interesante geopolítico de quién va a
ser más y más acciones para poder lograr
esa ese liderazgo dentro de la región y
es eso que podemos por eso por qué
motivo hemos visto diferentes países que
tienen contradicciones entre ellos pues
reconociendo a los parientes aquí en
juego que si lo estarían hacen saben
hacerla una lectura
política podría también el último es
beneficiar y consolidarse también dentro
de la región muchas piezas en este
rompecabezas muchos actores y una
disputa por afganistán que hay les ya
para ir cerrando el programa le pregunto
cuál cree usted que va a ser entonces
los movimientos que haga eeuu en el
futuro que puede hacer este país
simplemente olvidarse por completo de la
situación allí en el país asiático
evacuar a su personal diplomático y
militar y olvidarse del asunto o seguir
a nivel internacional atento a los
sucesos que tengan lugar allí
claro no pero la retirada de las tropas
y si retiramos el personal diplomático
es para su seguridad
abandonaremos a la región ya que ni
están por completo no no lo cree no es
de nuestro interés yo creo que esta
administración
ciertamente va a hacer consultas con
nuestros aliados para ver cómo la mejor
forma para avanzar en este momento
queremos esperar a ver cómo se
desenvuelve la situación allá pero yo
creo que en estos 20 años se han sentado
unas pautas que hasta los propios
líderes talibanes van reconociendo los
derechos de la mujer en las elecciones y
yo creo que
ellos a ellos realmente el reto es para
ellos yo creo que si quieren escoger un
camino pacífico y quieren que hacer un
gobierno que representa los afganistán
los de color afganistán entonces no no
creo que encontrarán la puerta cerrada
maria tereza conclusiones por acá para
ir cerrando el programa que vamos a
poder ver en los próximos meses en la
situación allí de pronto un conflicto
interno entre el talibán y estas fuerzas
de los señores de la guerra que se
quieren formar y acoplar para enfrentar
los escenarios son posibles el escenario
interno es bastante complejo una bola de
cristal no me dice mucho por dónde ir
pero si va a haber un problema con la
corrupción los talibanes se han vuelto
expertos en comprar el apoyo de la gente
no solo en pelear sino en comprarse el
apoyo entonces el conflicto interno
culturalmente en este monto en apoyar a
los talibanes por fin tienen un gobierno
de ellos no un gobierno impuesto por
potencias de occidente o por potencias
de otro lado china-rusia 200 años de
guerra yo creo que se la van a jugar a
ver si es posible desarrollar un
gobierno afgano para los afganos por
decirlo de alguna manera pero van a
tener muchos problemas derechos humanos
el problema de las mujeres el problema
de los refugiados
el problema de qué hacer con el que se
convenció del modo de vida americano y
ahora no lo tiene el problema de
venderse con credibilidad al extranjero
que dice esto les va a ahorrar tres
meses y en tres meses van a volver a lo
que eran antes pues van a tener que
jugar con la credibilidad y jugar con
los derechos humanos pero han aprendido
de relaciones públicas y han aprendido
que el sistema internacional existe en
este punto tiene el ojo sobre ellos y
veremos cómo lo manejan y que ellos han
sabido hacerle juego a ese escenario
internacional por tanto voceros para
ruedas de prensas ya salieron entrenados
sin dolo muchas relaciones públicas y
manuel su opinión para el cierre del
programa sobre lo que veremos más
adelante en esta coyuntura en afganistán
bueno yo creo que esto nos da varias
reflexiones la primera es que se
ratifica que siempre iniciar guerras es
fácil pero lo difícil es saber cuándo y
cómo se sale yo creo que lo segundo que
nos deja está esta situación es que
claramente en muchas ocasiones el poder
se emborracha más que el alcohol y ss
ese hecho hace que los estados cometan
imprudencias y finalmente yo creo que
también es una invitación a reflexionar
yo creo que es intervencionismo si estas
ideas de intervencionismos que se han
sucedido durante el siglo 20 pues no han
dado los buenos resultados como se
esperaba en su momento y hoy digamos
comparte lo que dice la profesora maría
teresa claramente hoy va a haber una un
juego político interno bastante fuerte
para consolidar el gobierno talibán no
la tiene fácil tampoco por las dinámicas
propias internas de los líderes
religiosos y políticos de las provincias
afganas y que obviamente van a ser van
hacia la lectura correcta política
podrán tener una mayor capacidad
diplomática para ver si ellos se logran
a hacer que la comuna internacional lo
reconozcan como un actor político
legítimo dentro del sistema
internacional pero vamos a ver y también
muy difícil el tema de las mujeres allí
y la comunidad del mundo entero está
encima de afganistán mirando cómo va a
ser el trato que le va a dar a las
mujeres ya los menores de edad por los
antecedentes que hubo durante su primer
digamos gobierno a finales de los 90
pues a maría teresa ya a caleb mccarry
ya manuel reirán muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros aquí en el
debate habernos explicado estas piezas
de este rompecabezas tan complicado que
es afganistán usted recuerde que pueden
seguir también dejando sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales y pueden seguir por supuesto en
la programación de france 24 siga con
nosotros
[Música]